good afternoon class of 2015
friends and family my name is British
Slater and I'm the senior class
committee representative for Kirkland
house today I am deeply proud and
honored to introduce my friend and
Kirkland brother Sam Clarke as your 2015
mail IV order graduating Phi Beta Kappa
Sam is a talented man who wears many
hats or maybe I should say he wears many
belts or better yet I could say he wears
many headdresses but we'll get there
soon able to do impressive flying high
kicks he co-founded the Crimson Kicks
youth martial arts program while at
Harvard in the Hasty Pudding theatricals
for four years and cast vice president
his senior year
Sam has worn many a feathery headdress
while performing in their renowned
burlesque cross-dressing musicals he is
also acted in numerous shows with the
Harvard Radcliffe dramatic Club and the
improv troupe on thin ice in these
performances Sam has done many hats but
perhaps his most famous is a Yale cap as
a Yale tour guide on yells campus
leading around tourists and aspiring
Yale ease
he filmed this wildly successful prank
on the sketch comedy news show on
harvard time and will continue to act
right and produce comedy in LA next year
Sam would like to thank his friends mark
Morello Gus my appleís Andrew Talbott
Forrest Neil the pudding casts and the
TOC from reaching his time here I'm
confident that Sam will be comfortable
addressing this large crowd since he was
our UC president for about seven minutes
so now I present to you Sam Clark your
2015 male ivy order
hello class of 2015
whoa yeah okay settle down welcome to
the historic tercer and tender rate to
the terse en turin - welcome to Harvard
Yard
hello seniors hello crying parents
texting siblings and sleeping
grandparents hello teaching fellows
young and old and tenured professors
sober and drunk kidding kidding
hello tenured professors drunk and hello
to Natalie Portman uh Natalie as an
aspiring actor myself I just wanted to
say that I really admire your work in
Star Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace
class of 2015 we graduate tomorrow my
mother tells me this is a big deal she
also tells me get a job and no seriously
get a job but whether I have a job or
not I will graduate tomorrow and I think
it's important to reflect upon what I
share with you all
we've all had different Harvard
experiences some of us have spent our
days here shaking hands with world
leaders and celebrities or creating new
iPhone apps or huffing 5-hour energy in
Lemont basement we all have different
views of how Harvard should change some
of us want smaller section sizes some of
us want Harvard to divest from fossil
fuels and some yeah and some of us just
want more tomato basil ravioli soup
and we all have different backgrounds we
have students from all over the world
like England or Kyrgyzstan or New York
or New York or New York but through all
these differences in experiences
worldviews and backgrounds one thing has
brought us together and guided all of
our actions in an incredibly important
way I'm not talking about the pursuit of
Veritas or our hatred of Yale or even
ghungroo I'm talking of course about the
Harvard Student Handbook which this
totally is that's right
without this 185 page tome of rules and
regulations governing this hallowed
institution Harvard would be nothing
more than a lawless wasteland without
the Harvard Student Handbook Dean of the
college Rakesh Khurana would have to
rule Harvard Yard like a Mad Max road
warrior running down underage drinkers
with a HUP d segue affixed with railroad
spikes confiscated key stones and the
skulls of freshmen who snuck flats in
the first chance dance without the
Harvard Student Handbook president drew
Faust would convene the ad board in the
blood-stained Stadium granting intro to
Congress students nothing more than a
dull sword to defend against vows
unfathomable fury her nicely pressed
pantsuit and a trident
without the harvard student handbook
deena freshmen Tom Dingman would
probably just keep being himself what a
dude but luckily we didn't have to think
about that
class of 2015 because the Harvard
Student Handbook has been there for us
when we registered for classes every
semester we entered a binding contract
that protected us under sacred Harvard
Law look how many of us actually read
the Harvard student handbook section kid
read it Mark Zuckerberg read it the I
guess those folks who ran that satanic
black mass thing probably read it pretty
thoroughly but the rest of us probably
didn't so who's to say we didn't enter a
contract granting Harvard our firstborn
child or selling Harvard our souls some
of the employed among us may be used to
such soul draining contracts shout out
McKinsey totally kidding totally kidding
I meant Bain kidding again I don't know
the difference but for the rest of us
I'll provide a little spark notes for
the provisions of the Harvard Student
Handbook that you may have missed
in some ways the Harvard Student
Handbook has guided us with simple
directives standards of conduct part
three don't steal general regulations
part eight no radioactive materials on
campus residential life part four
bicycles may not be written in Harvard
Yard these directives were simple and
obvious to nearly all of us except for
you idiots who rode bikes in the yard
like honestly you people were the worst
however not all regulations in the
Harvard Student Handbook were so clear
know some parts shifted and changed over
our four years at this school like all
great texts the Bible Plato's Republic
The Hunger Games part three Mockingjay
the Harvard Student Handbook has not
been static and unchanging its meaning
has evolved as we've matured the section
about honesty comes to mind I quote the
college expects that all students will
be honest and forthcoming in their
dealings with the members of this
community
freshman year this meant being really
really honest with every other freshman
you ever met in Annenberg about
everything in your life during these
meals I learned about the AP exam scores
political affiliations political
ambitions and deep-seated insecurities
of just about every other freshman I met
in Annenberg I even learned some
people's names but after we transitioned
to sophomore and junior year and realize
that no one cared about our AP exam
scores honesty came to mean something
different in this in these two years we
became honest with ourselves and found
our place on campus be it with a
talented group of performers in an
acapella group with a committed crew of
writers in a magazine or with the speed
club for gentlemen but senior year this
honesty extended to those outside the
Harvard community as we all began to
answer the perennial question what are
you doing next year and answering this
terrible terrible question honestly had
to become a little more creative if we
were going to be unemployed in our
parents basement we told people that we
were working on a start-up if we got a
consulting or finance gig we told people
we were moving to New York and if we
were spending a year traveling without a
job we told people we got a fellowship
all these answers were honest albeit
perhaps creative and interpretive and
who said the aesthetic and interpretive
understanding part of our gen ed
requirement was worthless haha I did I
said that but after tomorrow
class of 2015 the Harvard Student
Handbook will no longer bind us telling
us to be honest and the rule of Harvard
Law will no longer protect us it's been
our Guardian through thick and thin
through Hurricane Irene and Dean fee
stirs shroom emails on shrooms through
the politically controversial occupy
Harvard and the
little e silly 2014 you see election and
through Amy Poehler's parade down Mass
Ave and Dean Evelyn Hammonds parade
through our inboxes its Eldad so as we
head off into the real world the law of
Harvard will no longer help us we won't
have protection in the real world when
we try to pee on statues or run naked
through the streets with our fruit our
future brings us back here or back home
or god forbid back to the Gothic
architecture of New Haven the Harvard
student handbook will no longer be our
guardian angel
so here with you all as my witnesses
before we graduate and leave this
hallowed institution I will burn the
Harvard Student Handbook just kidding
that they wouldn't let me burn the
harvestin handbook but by the end of the
day I will eat it so cheers class of
2015 as I eat this handbook over the
course of this long day I will
internalize everything I've learned in
these four years of this school and I
hope that you will do the same I'll miss
you guys